holy crap I've I'm a bona fide superhero
and I want to look like this welcome
we're not getting robbed
oh hey stop I'm a superhero strong on
the suit for the first time was crazy it
was it was insane if it made it very
real in that moment it already it
already fell I mean look like I said I
mean even now it still doesn't feel
entirely real I'm talking about a movie
that hasn't come out yet but we're you
know so excited to bring to the people I
mean I've only ever seen people keep
asking me like how much have you seen
I'm like I've seen as much as you see
I've seen the trailer that's all yeah
that's all I see but I uh
but I have every confidence in David
Sandberg and Peter Safran our producer
and our executives a new line you know
and our executives at DC and Warner
Brothers I mean everybody really
believes in us in this project and and
believed in me and I'm like beyond
honored that they did but it's still all
kind of surreal but trying on the suit
definitely gave it a little bit more
reality to me and then being on set and
it you know being lit up and me with the
whole thing and cameras are rolling on
it's a practical life and that was
actually a moment that you know there's
a lot there's a lot of these moments in
the movie you know it would take like
six hours to shoot because we had like a
bunch of different cameras and this
lighting but you know just like Shazam
stands and looks you know this moment
and there's just you know a couple of
those moments there's one it's like this
like mist and fog and I'd like you know
I'm standing up I think his big strong
heroic pose and the light from my chest
was like shining through the the mist
and I and it it felt really cool in the
moment and then I went back and I
watched on the monitors and I was like
holy crap I'm a bona fide superhero and
I want to look like this just walk go to
Starbucks a lot to take a latte please
yeah it's a real so it's a practical
thing you're living that dream that that
few others have where you've gone from
Marvel to DC or vice versa yeah yeah I
have to ask you because you know the
Warriors three got a very unceremonious
send-off that was a little disappointing
and I don't know how you felt about it
but in hindsight now that your cast is
damn do you feel like that
was a blessing in disguise 100% so yeah
look in the in them in the midst of its
you know tyka what city is such a
talented director I it was very happy to
go and reprise Fandral even for a day in
Ragnarok just to work with him and to go
see Chris again and and and the various
people that we came over from from the
dark world and also you know to die at
the hands of Cate Blanchet is you know
if you're gonna die die at the hands of
Cate Blanchett but yeah it was it was a
bummer you know I mean I felt like oh my
god I got this I got to be a superhero I
got to be in this in the comic world of
movies and then wasn't really utilized
and then I was dead so it was a bit of a
bummer
all that said like you like you just
mentioned in hindsight you know if I
hadn't died in that movie there's a
chance there's a good chance that I
never would've gotten Shazam because I
my contract would still be active with
Marvel and who knows if they would have
all of a sudden if I was testing they
would have been oh we wanna hold onto
you because we're gonna go put you in
this and then have fan o speakers and
turn me to dust later I don't know it
all you know people say everything
happens for a reason you know I don't I
don't want to be so trite as to just
shove it off as that but 100% it worked
out in my favor and such an amazing
favor I mean I I can't think of another
superhero that I would rather play and
there's a lot of superheroes over the
years that I have really thought oh my
God if I could just play that character
if I could just play that character and
I wasn't even really aware of I knew
she's am very very cursory in passing
but didn't really understand that it was
essentially the movie big meets the
movie Superman and I get to play a 14
year old like I'm a man-child this is
the great it's like I barely have to act
have the time and you'd just be
enthusiastic and like be stoked to be a
superhero that's another thing a lot of
superheroes you know there's so much
like gravitas and
there
and that I oh I gotta go save the world
again and you know Billy Batson and like
maybe Peter Parker those are the only
two characters that I know I've been
king and incoming them that are just
beyond stoked that they have these
powers and they want to go run it like I
could fly I could y-you know it's it it
you get to the wish fulfillment that's
in the movie is also the wish
fulfillment of me and my own life which
is you know the parallels are beautiful
right we have so many reluctant heroes
and then he's like the eager here let me
get off yeah you know let me get a movie
that of your phone charge your phone
charge help a trailer just had me in
stitches um how would you say the tone
of Shazam is different from other DC
movies that we've seen well it's by its
own nature it's it's full of levity and
full of hearts yeah because it is about
a fourteen-year-old kid
and by the way and because it's based on
the new 52 comics there's a whole bunch
of other kids in this foster home that
Billy ends up with so you can't you
can't have a movie with a bunch of kids
in it and make it really you know hard-r
or whatever you can't have that crazy of
language or that crazy of visuals
because there's a lot of kids in it and
you need to kind of you know find that
balance other movies other superhero
movies are I think they they're hard at
work trying to find levity to build into
it this just already has it in there and
then it was more a matter of kind of
balancing out the grit and balancing out
the the kind of you know stakes and
everything which David Sandberg coming
from a horror background can do in
spades so I think that's one of the
biggest changes or the the biggest
differences in tone is that it is just
by nature got a lot of really fun you
know what what happens when you give a
14 year old that much power funny things
happen you know and what happens when
you give a 14 year old that is chosen
literally by the wizard to be given
these powers because he has a really
good heart I'm sure you thought pretty
quickly about the possibility of joining
the Justice League on screen 100% yeah I
was so I was flown in to LA to camera
for the role they put me up in a hotel
in Hollywood and then they you know the
the next day they drove me to Warner
Brothers did two camera tests and on the
way from Hollywood to Burbank there was
like two there was there were a few
billboards for Justice League as justice
league was up just about to come out and
I was on my way to go to my camera test
and I'm looking at all of those amazing
people and characters and I know the
comics well enough to know that Shazam
and many iterations is a part of the
Justice League so I'm on my way to
essentially go decide my fate or have
other people decide my fate and I'm
looking at these posters going if this
all goes well then I get this job and we
go make this movie and it and it does
well and this does well then I'll be on
theoretically I'll be on that next
billboard with all of you know all of
those characters and yeah so I haven't
just been thinking about it since I've
been the character I've been thinking
about it since well before I got the job
like come on please because oh man that
would be so much fun like you know the
youth of of like ezra's the flash and
and me as Shazam the way that we would
be kind of goofy together but also you
know I'm a 14 year old and they got
Wonder Woman there and like just having
a total crush on this like essentially
older woman and and like how do you how
do you act cool when you're you crushing
on the most beautiful friggin woman in
the world who also happens to be a
goddess and Amazonian goddess you know
and try and act cool around Superman and
Batman and all that stuff I mean I I my
brain was just immediately going to all
those possibilities because I think it'd
be a lot of fun yeah I was gonna ask you
which dynamic between your character and
what else you would like to see the most
but you pretty much ran through the
entire just all of it yes I'd like all
of the dynamics all of them yeah I think
the Nemesis well yeah flash and Shazam
would be a great super fun train we'd
literally be like racing each other I
mean I love that bit at the end of
Justice League wouldn't really matter
flash crazy but yeah Shazam and flash
would be doing it on a regular basis I
think I'd be trying to arm-wrestle
Superman all the time yeah we'd just be
goofing off I mean
I wanted to have a so bad so bad also in
the trailer we get some references to
the the Justice League we see that
what's Jack's character's name Freddy
Freddy yeah he's a fan of Batman and
Superman oh yeah yeah so does your
character then kind of get influenced by
what those those heroes do 100% so so
the our movie takes place very squarely
in the DC Universe in fact I would argue
that we're kind of the most self aware
of it because you know the movies that
we all watch and you know Aquaman and
Wonder Woman Batman Superman they're all
basically documentaries in in their
worlds these things of all these are all
real world events that have happened
Batman and Superman fighting Superman
saving all of Metropolis while
simultaneously destroying the entire
city that all really happens Justice
League really happened so these are real
figures and Freddie's obsessed with all
of them as our as our you know most kids
and people Billy just happens to not be
because Billy's been trying to find his
biological mother and he's on this whole
kind of fostering you know living on the
streets
Plus her kid journey but Freddy once
Billy gets this power he immediately
goes to Freddy saying like I don't know
how did you know I don't know how to do
any of this stuff I need your help and
so Freddy becomes the coach and through
that Billy learns a lot about all of
these other characters and I think that
helps definitely form his ability to go
and be the best superhero that he can be
have you heard of the Shazam Kazaam
controversy yes the genie thing yeah one
under percent when I got this job
everyone was like wait wasn't that the
Shaq movie when he was a genie I was
like no that's cuz am yeah cuz Shazam
was a movie genie movie starring Sinbad
it doesn't exist doesn't exist if this
is a complete Mandela effect thing and I
don't
I still haven't been able to figure this
out where did you remember that do you
have a memory of the same entity two
hundred percent no I did it was real I
remember it yeah but can you find it
online no you can so freaky I don't know
what's going on with this it's very very
very strange and all these parts of the
population remember it another part
stuff no I remember it I think I need to
go track down Sinbad and dingo pins ago
so he's tweeting about it and he was
like I was never in a movie genie movie
you guys are crazy
but it's not like you would mix up
Shaquille O'Neal and simbad no no no not
at all but also the name specifically
because Kazaam and although it sounds
similar is not Shazam and why would we
it's not like Shaq and one name of a
movie and Sinbad and another name of a
movie like that was a different thing
it's completely different thing
somebody did post online somewhere it
was like a little clip of like a kid
going through like a like an addict like
going through boxes or something and all
of a sudden
Sinbad popped down it's like yeah but
that's not actual evidence I don't know
what that is it was like some random
clip we gotta get to the bottom of No
I've got to find out yeah I feel like
we're in an alternate berenstain bears
universe this is all mendel effects
though just to wrap it up I know cuz you
were saying you grew up like loving all
these characters who was your favorite
character growing up in life I was a
really big into the mutant world so like
in Marvel I loved the x-men x-factor
exports I loved I just love the idea
that a regular person just out of
nowhere had a you know a genetic
mutation all of a sudden gave them some
superpower I'm still kind of waiting for
that to happen now do you do what I do
when you go out the grocery store and
you pretend you're a Jedi but I the the
automatic doors that are just bitter
just the ones that sent you which are
most automatic doors those are fine but
it's the ones I like to control them
with like the the handicap button
because those ones then then I feel like
I actually have more power over the door
otherwise you're just walking up and it
senses you but like if I can walk up and
like hit a button and then I can do this
and I open it then I feel very powerful
my pleasure thank you for a lovely
interview
[Music]